the film that actually changed my life
was Selma and Louise
uh made me realize in a very powerful
way how few opportunities we give women
to come out of a movie feeling excited
and empowered by the female characters
and this led me to have a very profound
interest in the way girls and women are
depicted in the world here's my theory
of change nearly every sector of our
society has a huge gender disparity
problem
but there's one category of gross gender
inequality where the underrepresentation
of women can be fixed absolutely
overnight on screen let's make this
change happen right now tomorrow morning
look at the projects you're working on
and do a gender and diversity pass don't
make one more movie without doing that
first let's do this okay thank you very
much